on avance quand même avec le ministre
sur beaucoup de pistes première piste et
il les a partagé d'ailleurs il y a
quelques jours avec l'ensemble des
acteurs première piste c'est cette
fameuse liste de médicaments critiques
sur laquelle on doit aboutir désormais
dans les dans les prochaines semaines
deuxième piste fondamentale je pense
pour les patients et pour les
professionnels comment on renforce la
communication et l'information souvent
les gens nous disent je sais pas ce qui
se passe et ça je pense que c'est une
source de stress à la fois pour le
pharmacien et pour le patient qui est en
face de lui comment ça vous savez pas
mais qu'est-ce que ça va ça va se
résoudre quand qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire donc là on a un rôle clé du
pharmacien comme toujours comment est-ce
qu'on renforce l'information des
pharmacies d'officine c'est tout le
l'enjeu des logiciels fiables des
perructures pousser de l'information
directement depuis la NSM même chose
pour les établissements de santé avec là
encore des groupes de travail qui sont
sur la participation avec la DGOS du LEM
du GEM du Conseil de l'Ordre des
pharmaciens et en associant les
fédérations de patients alors c'est ça
qui est un peu particulier en France
c'est que pour les patients atteints de
maladies chroniques les fédérations sont
très structurées et souvent les patients
sont très bien informés parce que ils
sont dans des boucles d'informations etc
pour un patient où j'allais dire avec
une pathologie aiguë ou un événement
aigu c'est plus compliqué parce qu'il a
pas forcément cette information donc il
faut aussi que le site de la NSM soit le
plus on va dire
pédagogue et accessible au grand public
troisième axe c'est celui du plan blanc
qui est un terme nouveau dans le champ
du médicament et ça ça met en mode crise
tout ce qu'on a déjà des détaillés
devant vous c'est derrière à la fois la
réponse européenne de type era les
capacités de l'EMA de la cartographie
des risques et de répondre uniquement
aux crises mais de façon beaucoup plus
puissante puisque européenne et puis au
niveau national la NSM les plans de
gestion des pénuries les stocks et donc
des solutions clés en main qu'on aurait
déjà testé on en a testé quelques-unes
pendant la pandémie mais qu'on mettrait
en action de extrêmement efficace en
mode dégradé face à face à une crise
majeure et puis probablement et ça c'est
un effet nouveau de cette de cette
saison 2022 tout à fait exceptionnel
davantage tenir compte de la
saisonnalité ça peut paraître étrange
mais on voit bien
qu'il y a des pics de consommation et
c'est pas c'est pas une critique dans ma
bouche mais effectivement si tout le
monde a mal à la tête et qu'on a tous la
vie rose c'est logique qu'on aille tous
allez en pharmacie chercher de quoi se
de quoi se réduire nos symptômes donc ça
c'est c'est ça fait des pics évolutifs
de consommation que les pharmaciens
décrivent très bien des moments on leur
réclame pas du tout de médicaments et
puis trois semaines après il y a une
demande d'un seul coup qui qui peut
exploser et ça c'est difficile pour les
la chaîne du médicament de l'anticiper
donc le producteur n'a pas anticipé donc
les grossistes répartiteurs sont en
tension et les officines se retrouvent
confrontés à des difficultés majeures
donc l'anticipation pour nous c'est
important alors anticipation par les
professionnels anticipation par les
sociétés savantes par les hôpitaux tout
ça on l'a dit mais aussi par des signaux
faibles qui sont émis par exemple par
iqvia par Gers par un certain nombre de
de personnes qui sont en amont du
circuit
c'est pas la réponse et je tiens
vraiment à être précis quand je dis que
on a manqué dans la boxicilline c'est
pas parce que on en consomme trop je
suis quand même très conscient de ça
mais il y a une partie de la réponse qui
passe par les bonnes pratiques par les
bonnes pratiques le bon usage donc
savoir que on ne fait pas
d'automédication que c'est pas la peine
d'avoir de trop de boîtes à la maison
que c'est pas la peine non plus d'aller
se précipiter quand on entend que une
tension parce que sinon ça crée des
tensions complémentaires donc toute
cette partie de recommandation du bon
usage avec un une participation très
forte de nos collègues pharmaciens de
nos collègues prescripteurs et des
patients ça va être très important et
puis enfin un axe qui est moins dans le
champ de la DGS mais qui évidemment
important c'est tout l'axe production et
donc comment est-ce que on arrive à
mettre en place une doctrine là encore
facilitant la cartographie complète des
des capacités de production de la chaîne
de production parce que souvent on a une
anticipation très importante si on a
l'information très très en amont et
c'est ce que c'est ce que souhaite la
NSL